le ramadan représente pour moi d'avancer
un mois béni
que dieu un sujet pour nous et de la
doré en s'abstenant de ce que nous avons
commandé dans le courant donc c'est à
dire éviter les péchés et éviter aussi
les énerver les gens de ne jamais l'on
n'ait provoqué on dit jeunes jeunes donc
en tout et à londres du créateur c'est à
dire on doit s'abstenir manger boire et
on n'a pas de rédaction et relations
sexuelles avec nos femmes dont d'anciens
docks juste du début du début
c'est-à-dire la première pierre de
l'homme
au fait le sort des petits déjeuners
villepin ont fait la prière et jusqu'au
coucher du soleil
le soleil on va faire la rupture et à ce
moment là je précise bien donc il y en a
qui vont manger très peu la route chez
quelques dates un peu de lait un peu
d'eau et d'autres aussi qui peuvent
obtenir la maison pour s'hydrater bord
de l'eau manger un peu plus y revenir
chaque il ya une cuillère là les petits
du courant qui se fera lors de la
dernière prière voilà c'est une durée
d'un an à peu près il n'ya alors après
cette rupture de prier assez tous les
jours le ramadan
se terminera le 5 juin c'est adam tu
t'es fixé la date du 5 juin il y a quand
même deux moments forts dans ce ramadan
il y a donc la nuit du destin
et puis la clôture du ramadan lui même
ni tout à fait la nuit du destin c'est
voilà ce jour dans les 10 derniers jours
donc certains cerveaux ont donné notre
27 mai pour se faire à chercher du vin
jusqu'à
au trentième jour de ramadan et qu'est
ce qui se passe à ce moment et à ce
moment donc laisser faire voir les gens
venir fait plus de 2,2 de charitable et
enfin la ferme tout ce que dieu aime à
ce moment là donc c'est très important
donné et ce tony plus est ce que c'est
la fin quand on s'approche de la fin
donc c'est vous savez c'est comme on dit
olly moss mc le watson que dieu donne
plus d'une tonne puis tu fais des
protections plus dieu te récompense
et après ce moment là donc il ya la
haine et pour la clôture vers le mâle de
télérama takis à la fête de l'aïd
donc ça c'est l'événement si tout le
monde c'est de fait on est content
famille et si les enfants les comptes en
est là c'est un jour magnifique voix la
mjc plus participation aussi voilà pour
ce que politique pour sacrifier denis ou
nécessitent une nécessité donné ce jour
là ses dessins geoffroy s'est d'ailleurs
c'est les deux fêtes de l'aïd kaunas et
qu'après avoir